[Music]
young dems don't get a pass when old
tweets bite them in the ass a bombshell
reported politico highlights allegations
of bigotry and calls for impeachment of
high-ranking members of the college
democrats of america or
it's the worst student scandal since i
was caught in a dorm during a panty raid
that was last year
and i still haven't got my panties back
yeah screenshots of their old tweets
from adolescents have been circulating
which has led to ugly accusations of
anti-blackness islamophobia and
anti-semitism it's gotten so bad the dnc
may cut ties with their college
counterparts what do they got against
ties and the college kids are so upset
they're using their tears to fill their
bongs as the piece points out some
college dems see it as a morally
necessary reckoning with systemic racism
of course while others see it as a bunch
of college-educated hyper-woke kids
trying to play politics which sounds
like the democratic party so all this
drama over resurfaced tweets from long
ago hmm i wonder how far this will go
all right mr angelic you have a great
resume but could you explain this tweet
from 2018
who's in the mood for a little mexican i
think her name is rosalita
oh uh that was a joke we were gonna meet
up for tacos
did you also write this sexist comment
in a yearbook had a blast in ap english
mrs thompson was a [ __ ] ha ha have a
great summer
that's from when i was in high school
and mrs thompson was a [ __ ]
isn't it also true you once soiled
yourself while grabbing a woman's
breasts no way when is that from
1970 i was a baby i was a hungry baby
yes but it happened once again in 1990
2005 and just last week
oh
uh
damn it
[Music]
joe
you look like a college professor of the
kind that would hit on college students
uh why don't college
doesn't it it's pretty accurate right
with the beard salt and pepper beard
that was that in confidence great yes
i look like a a professor hit on girls
at a community college
can we pause to acknowledge my
incredible acting in that bible
you're a natural you're a natural those
improv classes that you spent your uh
eight grand well spent yes what um why
is it it's never this isn't a problem
with college republicans only college
democrats are you kind of enjoying it oh
it's wonderful to see them eating
themselves like that it's great it's uh
you know to to see that it really has
nothing to do with justice or anyone's
feelings it's just a game of moving up
in your status to see who can be more
aggrieved and yeah and the idea that the
democratic party would be cutting ties
with them because well if there's one
thing they won't stand for it's
bickering over race and identity issues
the democrats certainly don't want any
of that so it's a lot of fun it reminds
me the quote it's a shame they can't
both lose so i would love to see them
tearing each other apart yeah you know
cat this is uh this is what happens when
forgiveness is considered a vice like if
you if you actually say you know that it
was that was a long time ago they go no
now you're going to be canceled as far
as i know all the college democrats do
is release statements condemning stuff
for the past few years so they just got
lazy now they're just condemning each
other which is a lot easier but the only
concern is that college democrats after
a few years they become grown-up
democrats right
and then they get jobs maybe in hr they
there it's always 18 and it's going to
be hr and we're all
yes
yeah that's strange man i thought i was
so wrong i thought that the stuff would
be localized in academia and then but no
it jumped out it found its place
actually in the corporate world a
corporate world matt that are that is so
desperate to virtue signal that they'll
buy anything they'll spend money on
anti-racism ideology crt like that well
and it's not long you know we're going
through old tweets old social media for
these college students it's not long
before corporate america starts going
through every email you ever sent oh god
and just yeah well you saw that happen
to john gruden recently where you know
that his emails were legal pictures i
sent to you yeah
everybo i thought everybody works out
naked
anyway i apologize for that but it is it
is uh it's crazy because they are being
hoisted what is it on their own
on their own pitard no one knows what a
batard is yes right well you can be
hoisted on it it must be long yes
exactly not for me
uh i don't even pitard sounds like
something that should be banned julie
yeah um
we should rise above this and defend
these kids except you know that these
kids would be the first ones to try to
cancel you no totally you work at fox i
would cancel myself yes i want to cancel
myself you've been trying to cancel
yourself yeah i really try so much
but i am so grateful this reminds me of
how grateful i am that there was no
social media when i was growing up
because
nobody nobody has any record of all the
stupid that i did i mean you have no
idea but um but i think it's interesting
and i think i like the fact that they
are very consistent in following in the
footsteps of their democratic leaders in
washington where they are leading a
party of dysfunction um where it begins
in college and then of course they
become adults um they should actually
look into kamala harris's office see if
she's hiring because i think that
there's a whole field of potential
candidates there yes that she could
potentially use to you know better her
position further her dysfunction yeah
exactly
you know what the only person that is
immune from cancellation is the least
interesting people on earth if there
isn't something that you're going oh god
i hope that doesn't get out
i don't want to know you i don't have
anything i don't want to know you like
who here doesn't have a sex tape oh my
god you know what i mean well i've got
an it's i got a library
i'm so thankful people don't have vhs oh
i just finally albuquerque
anymore mine's on betas
you were a master at beta
oh
stopped into malone with that one
terrible
terrible god this is this show is
getting dirtier and dirtier every day
they're gonna have to stop it i don't
underst i don't understand any of it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else